I'm going to teach you to be about
complex numbers today a very very very
small amount just enough to understand
what's going on yeah and get to the
fractals but um hopefully it will make
all right so he's a new intern sequence
that I'm interested in okay I'm going to
write it in a bit of a funny way okay
okay now just a couple of things right
that's a said I write my his ends with
the dash through them because when I'm
in a hurry
my sins start to look like twos right I
don't know if you're the same but you
know it's particularly in exam I just
don't want up so I write all my sins
with dashes - okay what's going on here
we usually use X in here right X is out
kind of I learned of it's it's the
preferred under right we're choosing
said because we're looking at a
different family of numbers complex not
message the significance of it I will
explain okay now this C here like is
going to be a particular number I want
to try out different values of C okay so
this is another another song I'm putting
two numbers into this okay so for
instance well let's have a look at a
series like okay let's try this one F of
zero
okay now I'm sorry with simple examples
okay
what's gonna happen here this C is is
zero okay so I'm always going to start
from zero I'm gonna be right and see
what happens okay so let's give it a go
if I start with F 0 of 0 okay what do
you get you get 0 stands for 0 which is
0
yeah oh okay well that means I've got 0
now and I iterate right I'm gonna go
back to this step I'm gonna get 0 again
so I get this this is the sequence then
I am did I get out of this right so
you're like okay not very interesting
okay well that's fine
it's zero squid wait yes no yes I'm
making Z I'm starting with zero I always
start with zero okay so this guy in here
he's kind of er is what I is what I put
in okay so in this case really I should
have written zero squared plus zero
following it okay so this particular
value hmm seems to be not very
interesting okay but there are other
values I can throw in here how about for
instance let's see what happens with one
I want you to try give you guys you can
tell me what you get actually what's up
what's that first one it's just one well
actually the first one is zero then you
get one right and then what happens
after what and then what happens five
five squared plus one is 26 okay 26
squared okay let's see this is a bit
harder it'll be in the six or seven
hundred six hundred six hundred and
sixty six plus one so 677 okay now I'm
impressed by 26 min but I didn't think
anyone's gonna do so if you're
calculating it I'm done like right good
what plus one plus one 331 did you - 330
and then do I had one
oh wow oh yeah of course
yeah bat sorry okay yeah so yeah
all right now I don't know it can I
calculate this to do the next one or
does it get too big just try it just try
it I just want her laid or your phone
calculator might do you a little better
because I think it's got more diligence
it's uh it's twelve digits two one zero
zero six six and I'll add one yes okay
all right so you're like okay what's
happening to this where would you
dynamic sequences right now what you've
got we've noticed two different things
here okay and we started weird what
happens if you know we're all out as ed
it's always stay with zero and then we
go and go and go and go we internment
okay but what we're modifying each time
is this numbering here what's that
what's that see that constant flying on
the end there okay and what impact
doesn't have okay so we have seen just
two examples and they are different the
first example is what we called bounded
okay in other words the terms of the
sequence they didn't really go anywhere
okay they don't get they don't progress
they don't increase the size or anything
like that
this you might be able to guess you know
the numbers just sort of explode right
so what might we call it instead about
it
unbounded right okay rebound there's no
limit to how large these numbers get and
that makes sense right there's nothing
that would ever make it smaller okay cuz
you're squaring things in logic okay now
he's except about it he's an example of
unbalanced I would like you to try and
see right and you could do this in a
pair if you like because you're gonna be
testing out some numbers can you
generate some other numbers that will
give you bounded dynamic sequences
versus unbalanced some what about it and
so will be unbounded
okay fine work out is there any kind of
pattern okay so where's the other other
people
- here we go I can tell you now there
are summer in both calories you should
be able to play but see if you can work
out what makes it one of the other oh
just because it got raised before this
bad example maybe I should have given
you another one another example of a
bounded dynamic sequence and maybe you
are about to try this one already but
yeah look how good positive numbers in
for C right there's nothing to say you
have to be positive right for instance
let's go negative one it's good negative
brother okay so this is is N squared
minus one okay so you start with zero I
reckon we can do this in our heads right
so stick seer a nor what happens you get
zero squared minus one so you get
negative one right okay now stick that
back in you get negative one squared
which is one minus one which is zero
which is then going to remember because
they matthew from one to another the
next one's going to be negative 1 and
zero so this is not the same as this but
it's still it's not still bounded right
it's never gonna go in skyrocket it'll
never get out of this it's kind of
locked in so I've given you two bounded
ones for free in one unbounded one see
if you find a few more and work out
what's going on